it felt like there was a couple of
records that you dropped that like felt
very uh forced
yeah you know and i
i agree the thing is with me i can kind
of make any kind of genre of music right
and that's not like trying to big myself
up too much it's just the truth you feel
me like i can go in the studio with any
person from any background any language
anywhere in the world and i'm gonna make
a slap with you so
like
i'm always down to try some [ __ ] but i'm
realizing oh i'm trying this and y'all
are excited about it because you're just
thinking dollar signs and that's not how
art is supposed to be made
you feel me like quincy jones
told me
and it's the truest thing the moment
you're in the studio and you start
thinking about money or you start
thinking about financial success and
that's what you're talking about
god gets up and leaves and if god is not
in there making songs with you what
makes you think it's going to be hard
it's not everything that's fire in the
world is fire because god helped it be
lit like that
like if he's not in the studio with you
making music it's not going to slide and
the moment you start focusing on
money that's just not going to slap so
it's like yo
um yeah just some of those records i
felt like were uh we're doing this
because
i'm so nice and i'm trying to appease
this uh y'all just want another yeah
massive massive song and it's like i
can't i can't spend my time doing it